This video is brought to you by Squarespace from websites to online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Had to squarespace.com for a free trial and when you're ready for launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics to save 10% of your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Alexander the Great's stood at the head of the world's most feared army using it
to conference self and absolutely vast empire.
He crushed the Persian empire and then thrust his way into Egypt and India to
become the acknowledged king of kings spend at the height of his power,
he was cut down leaving behind a legacy of heroism,
divinity,
tyranny,
and today's biographics.
We examined the incredible life of Alexander
the future.
Alexander the great who was born in Pella,
Macedonia,
the capital of ancient Greece,
because the Greeks used a different calendar than we do.
We can't actually say for 70 when exactly he was born.
Most historians believe that he was born on July the 20th 356 BCE.
He was the son of the king of Mastodon Phillip,
the seconds and the principal,
one of his seven wives Olympia's of apparatus as the son of the King Alexander,
he was raised by a nurse,
had private tutors with the first one being a relative by the name of Liana
does.
This man was a strict teacher who demanded a high level of academic rigor of the
young prince.
Liana does Alexandra in such subjects as maths,
reading and languages at around the age of seven I think it all just started
instruction under one of his father's generals,
a man by the name of the Leisa mcass of Archimania,
his drawl boys to teach the boy to behave like a noble.
Alexander was taught to play the liar as well as to ride and to hunt.
Bison.
Marcus also gave them instruction in fighting.
When he was 10 years old,
Alexander's father was presented with a horse for sale by a trader,
but the horse,
it was wild and no one could mount it for NYP was about to dismiss this
straighter.
When y'all Alexander stepped forward and said that he was able to team the
animal.
The boys set himself,
so breaking the animal,
Lynn's becoming it's monster.
This was a dangerous task even for a grown man,
but young Alexander showed impressive determination and perseverance to conquer
this horse.
His father,
the king was so proud of his son that he even gave way to tears.
He told his son,
my buy,
you must find a kingdom big enough for your ambitions.
Mastodon is too small for you.
After saying this,
he purchased the horse for him.
He named the horse view syphilis,
which means ox set.
He rode the horse over most of his career and he carried it with him and too
many battles.
When we sat,
Willis died of old age at 30 Alexander,
you named just city off to him when he was 13 Alexander is education.
It was taken to a new level.
When Phillip employed the greatest philosopher of the day,
Aristotle to tutor his son.
The daily lessons were held at the temple of Nymphs of Mesa.
Alexander's lived there with other royal children and a sort of very privileged
version of a boarding school.
Some of the teenagers that Alexandra associated with at that time would later
become his generals.
Aristotle provided instruction in religion,
morals,
philosophy,
art,
and there's logic in appreciation for the education that he was providing for
his son.
The King Rebuilt Aristotle's home in the town of staggy wrap.
This said previously been destroyed by the same king.
He also purchased every save in the town and freed them.
When he reached the age of 16 Alexander was handed a huge responsibility.
His father had just declared war on Byzantium and he was a bouncer lead his army
into battle.
He left the Capitol City of Macedonia under the control of Alexander.
It was a huge display of trust on behalf of the king.
This others soon took advantage.
A group of European tribes known as the three C and made he rose up in rebellion
under the impression that the kingdom was weakened under the teenage prince.
But Alexander,
he was up to the challenge.
He sent his army in and the three seasons were quickly driven out of their
territory.
Yeah,
the area repopulated with Griggs and renamed it Alexandropolis.
When King Philip returned from battle,
he was extremely impressed with the way that his son had dealt with the three C
in revolt.
He gave Alexander his own small army and did the drop of stomping out.
Any minor revolves that crops up throughout the empire.
Over the next three years,
Alexander,
he joined his father on a number of military campaigns to dominate the Greek
states.
On one occasion it was claims there's Alexander saved his father's life during a
campaign against the Greek state of parenthesis.
They defeated the cities of a [inaudible] and um,
up then they come up against the of the armies of Athens and Thebes.
They always measuring an epic battle.
Nick irony and Biasha Phillips took the right wing of the army and put the left
wing under Alexander with Macedonia as top generals having to answer to him the
Thebes Thebesians Athenians defeated giving Philip control of the majority of
the Greek states.
He then said about you're noting them into a Hellenic alliance,
having stamped his dominance on a largely United Greece.
Phillip set his sights on conquering Persia this time he'd left his son in
control of a hugely extended empire.
When he returns,
Phillip added an extra wife to his household.
Her name was Cleopatra.
You read a scene.
This marriage put Alexander's position is that of the throne in danger?
Cleopatra?
It was a full Macedonian.
Well,
Alexander was only half Macedonian this man's that.
If Cleopatra had a son,
this one would supersede Alexander in the line of succession during the wedding
feast at a loss,
the uncle of Cleopatra who was one of Phillip's top generals was heard to drunk
and the requests of the gods that looking and his new bride should quickly
produce a son.
Alexander heard the plea and it was not happy.
He went up to the general and threw a cup in his head and said,
you villain.
What am I?
Then a bastard,
Alexander felt abandoned by his father after the wedding in his mother left
Mastodon and headed for apres where a mother's brother,
King Alexander the first presided leaving his mother there.
He continued on to Elyria in the western part of the Balkan peninsula.
He was welcomed as a dignitary by the Hillary and king back in Macedonia,
but king was saddened by his sons departure.
He sent a messenger to persuade addicts to reten they're islands.
He was that Philip had never intended to displace Alexandre a Zap.
However,
shortly after Alexander's returned to Mastodon,
there was more tension between the two.
Phillip arranged for Alexander's younger brother were also called fit up to Mary
Alexander.
Alexander's trouble making friends persuaded him that the king was again trying
to constantly call from inheriting the throne.
However,
when for the poet of the room as he angrily banished the troublemakers
in October of 336 BC,
the Macedonian Royal Court was in ag for the wedding of Alexander,
the first of us and Alexander's sister,
Cleopatra of Macedonia.
Phillip was assassinated by one of his bodyguards as he entered into the towns
theater.
The reasons for the assassination around clear,
but the results was very clear.
20 year olds,
Alexander was now king of Macedonia.
Alexander was shaken by his father's murder.
He knew that the plotters were intent on stealing the thrown out from under him.
If he didn't take decisive action,
he too would she be debt?
He began by having his cousin.
I meant just the fourth put to death along with a pair of Macedonian princes
from [inaudible].
He also ordered the execution of atlas,
the uncle of his step mother,
Cleopatra,
his mother Olympia's.
So danger in the form of Cleopatra.
The women who had married Philip a few years earlier.
She had arranged for Cleopatra runs the daughter she had had with Philip to be
killed.
She also poisoned others and even some of the mentally and physically disabled
for life.
Alexander was furious.
It his mother poisoning his half sister who he didn't consider it to be a threat
to him when the news that the stable dominant rule of Philip had been replaced
by his 20 year old son,
a number of states where in Boldens do rise up in revolts.
Recently,
concrete states,
including Athens and fessel Omika attempted to reassign it to their
independence.
Despite his advice edging a diplomatic response,
Alexander was determined to stamp his dominance on the rebellious states.
He personally led a force of 3000 soldiers to sort things out.
In many cases,
the uncooperative states resistance evaporated at the site of Alexandra at the
head of his army.
Those who didn't sweat put down very swiftly.
He rode through the various states that his father had,
United and Xander.
He was heaped with praise.
His swift action had cemented his power and it's provided a seamless transition
from his father's rule to his having put down a series of revolts.
Alexander at wants to do it and show that the way.
No further uprisings.
In his second year as king,
he took his own east and defeated the Tracy and people who had rebelled against
him four years ago.
He also conquered the Trib Aldi tribe.
By now Alexander's Macedonian Kingdom.
It didn't become so large that if he went north to put down a rebellion,
people in the south would rise up.
Then when he went south for those in the north would rebel again.
What was needed was a show of dominance that would prevent feather uprisings
within northern states,
brought them control.
Alexander took his armies south.
He went directly to thieves.
The only southern states,
which a dead to rebel Alexandre he was getting to make an example of them.
The city,
it was completely destroyed.
Even created a series of smaller cities that were populated with people from
other areas.
This assault,
it had finally brought all of Greece under Alexander's Dominion.
He now says,
how have to conquer Asia to keep the home kingdom under control?
He bit a general by the name of Antipasto in charged with a size of alarmy army.
Hmm.
In 334 BCE,
Alexander marched to 40,000 strong army out of Macedonia.
He was focused on taking possession of the entire Persian empire,
which he considered to be a person or a gift to him from the gods.
Unlike his father,
Alexander was never really interested in achieving diplomatic negotiations.
He was all about taking what he wants it by force of arms.
The first resistance that the Macedonian army found as they swept into Persia
was it the battle of Granicus river?
This river was a formidable obstacle that the Greek army would have to cross the
Persians under the Memnon of roads,
position themselves around the river and we'll just do await the arrival of the
enemy.
Their strength was a little over half of that at the Greeks.
Alexander led his army into a direct frontal attack using a classic wedge shape
to salts.
They drove into the middle of the Persian line in the ballet that followed.
It was reported that Alexander personally killed several Persians.
He was almost filled with an ax player,
but he was able to recover and save himself the superior numbers of the Greeks
combined with their use of the lunch counter.
The javelin and attacks of the Persians eventually won the day.
The Persians,
they were defeated and chased from the field.
Social version casualties were around 4,000 with Alexander's army having lost a
10th of that number,
there had been about 18,000 Greek nurse and race.
He fought for the Persians in this battle.
They were captured by the Greek army.
I think Zonda considered these men to be traitors to their country and deserving
of no mercy.
He had half of them executed and the rest taken as slaves.
Following this victory,
Alexandra took possession of scientists,
the provincial capital of the Kingdom of video.
He then traveled down the Ionian coast.
Most towns welcomed him as a conqueror and Z.
Do you need to clouds that?
They were free of that Persian overlords and able to rule themselves.
There's a ton of mistakes.
As he moved down the coast,
the Persian navy was constantly trying to engage Alexander in battle.
However,
he resisted.
Preferring to fight on the lambs.
Moving south.
Alexander came to Haluk analysis where he engaged in his first full scale CG
operation.
The Persian fleet is sales to the port of how to can asas where it's set up.
A base.
Prior to Alexander's arrival,
the queen of how to kinesis eight or of carrier had been driven from the city
and replaced by a sash trap named or onto Beatty's eight or had set itself up in
the fortress of a Linda.
When Alexander wrote in,
she surrendered the fort to him,
the defenders of the city of how they can asses now set up to defend the city.
Still Alexon doesn't allow me a managed to break through the city walls,
how that they were driven back by the catapults from within the city,
a renewed assaults.
I became this parallel and stormed through a second time.
Memnon of Rhodes.
He was in defense of the city having evaded capture at Granicus river set the
city on fire before retreating the Persian fleets.
They also withdrew Alexander formally it return the city to queen eater.
In return.
She adopted him as a son,
that for making sure that the city would pass to him.
I'll have death,
so do you mind nobody be out.
Then it conquering the welds,
but if you want to conquer the Internet for yourself,
your brands and your business,
why you should do it with Squarespace.
See what I did.
They're pretty good transition,
right?
Squarespace and empowers dreamers,
makers and doers like Alexander the Great.
If he was around today,
he'd be using Squarespace.
It gives people the tools to bring their creative ideas to life.
Squarespace makes it easy to,
they have an all in one platform so you can claim a domain,
build their websites and even sell online.
There's no fussing around is getting a domain from one place and bringing it
over to another.
Then working out how to sell something or whatever.
It's all just done neat and tidally on Squarespace.
That's pretty nice.
Plus it's not going to look too shabby either.
Am I not too shabby?
I mean,
it's going to look pretty fantastic.
They've got award winning templates,
which is a perfect starting point.
Then you then just customize those templates until your heart's content and it
looks just how you want it.
They've also got 24 seven customer support by chat or email and also got loads
of accessible and not confusing documentation on how to make a great website
plus email marketing so you can keep in touch with your fans or your customers.
Look Squarespace,
it makes it easy,
so get that domain,
get that slide belt,
get up a shop if you want to and you're good to go.
Just that discretion based.com for a free trial and when you're ready to go
launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash buyer graphics and save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Let's get back to Alexander and his conquering of the world.
Control of helicon Asas and the coastal cities meant that the Persians could no
longer doc their fleet.
Continuing on his conquest,
Alexandra arrived did the Phrygian capitol of Gaudium.
There was here according to Greek legend that he was taken before rate famed
Oxcart,
which was tied with an incredibly complicated rope,
not known as the Gordian Knot.
It was whoever could undo the knot would become ruler of Asia.
Alexandra is said to have examined the knots closely then having no idea how to
undo it.
He pulled out his sword and to cut the ribbon half with a single stroke.
We don't know whether the story is true,
but you know it makes very good tale.
Continuing South Alexander's army and counsel for the first time a more
formidable army than his own.
It was under the leadership of Darious,
the third king of the Hakim and at empire of Persia does my being outnumbered,
Alexander's tactical skill and just personal bravery and leading from the front.
They won the day Darious.
He was completely overwhelmed by this loss he took to his heels before leaving
his army,
a great treasure and all of his kingdom.
Alexander claimed at all
with the absolute dominance of Alexander's Greek army over the Persians
bordering nations began to panic.
The all conquering warrior king has developed an aura of invincibility and many
nations simply a seeded to him as he entered that territory by 332 he had taken
Syria and the coastal advance.
Then had about taking tire,
which was a coastal islands based,
sitting about a mile out in the Mediterranean Sea.
Conquering the islands would be a great challenge to Alexander with the
combination of sea and high walls that surrounded the islands and in with very
few options for seven months,
Alexander blockaded,
the island's preventing either entry or exit.
He then had his ami build a causeway out of rocks in order to allow them to get
to the city walls when the city walls well eventually breached.
Alexander was so angry with the extended Terry and holds out to this.
According to contemporary historian Arion of [inaudible] media,
he ordered the massacre of up to 8,000 citizens following the taking of ta.
Most of the cities on Alexander's campaign roots surrendered without putting up
any resistance.
They only one city that stood fum as he wound his way to Egypt was up as the
city centers top of a hill.
It looked as if Alexander was in for another protracted siege.
Yeah,
this was one siege that sort of look like an impossibility.
The walls were according to Alexander's engine is too high and too thick to be
penetrated.
For Alexander,
they,
this was just the soldiers of challenge.
As chiefs is flooding,
he became even more determined to conquer the city.
He was convinced that destiny was going to find a way for him.
The Greek call me mate three desperate attempts to breach the walls.
Eventually on the final day,
they made that breakthrough,
but the cost,
it was terrific with thousands of men folding to the missiles of the enemy.
Alexander himself suffered a serious shoulder wound.
Once the city was taken,
severe punishments was exacted upon the inhabitants with the men being
slaughtered in the women and children being sold into slavery.
When the will conquer in Greek army approached the holy Jewish city of
Jerusalem.
The Jews throw open the gates and welcomes admins that midst.
It was reported that Alexander was taken into the Great Temple of Solomon and
shown a prophetic text from the book of Daniel that referred to him as a mighty
king who would conquer the land.
I think it after recent and peace and headed south to they claim to Egypt.
In that land,
he was welcomed as a liberator.
The people were proclaimed him to be a son of the gods and gave him reverends on
the same level as though in Pharaoh he founded the city of Alexandria,
which would become a major trading center in future times
leaving Egypt.
Alexander traveled back north as he set his sights on taken Babylon.
This is the Persian capitol where King Darious had positioned himself.
Alexander marched with 47,000 men,
but Darious had amassed a massive army,
which some historians have put at 1 million men.
The two armies met near the village of Greg Mella at the forefront of his lines.
Darious place chariots armed with sides and 15 elephants in another time to do
move through the Greek lines.
In response,
Alexander placed his light to troops up front to negate the effects of the
chariots with missiles directed at their horses.
Those chariots that made it to the Greek line,
we're allowed to pass harmlessly through where they were surrounded and
captured.
Darious himself was in a sidearms chariots,
which when the idea was felled by a javelin,
he jumped from the chariot,
mounted a horse and flat seeing this many of his own men.
They followed suit.
Panic ensued and the battle was over.
Following the conquest of battle on Alexander moved on to Susa and then to the
Persian city of Persepolis.
Even at the time,
ends to hunt down and kill Darious,
the disgraced Persian king.
In order to prevent any further reprisals,
he finally found areas,
but he had already been killed.
One of his most trusted men,
Bassa said,
killed him and now claimed the throne for himself,
not links on that announced that it is science on tracking down best who would
flood into Central Asia.
Alexandra explored much of Asia.
He founds a number of cities naming each of them in his own honor.
Eventually basis was betrayed by his own men and handed over for execution.
On his returned to Persia,
Alexander,
he was hailed as the king of kings.
He began to adopt Persian habits including dressing and Persian clothing and
following Persian customers.
This was troubling.
So many Greeks,
including some of his generals.
By now,
Alexander had been away from Mastodon for many years.
He had left Antipater is the military ruler of the city and he had effectively
maintain the peace.
However,
Alexander was obstinately requesting trip reinforcements,
which made the defenses of the city weaker.
Alexandra now set his sights on conquering the Indian subcontinent.
He sent delegates ahead of him,
do demands that the Indian leaders submit to him.
Some of the clans acquiesced,
but others didn't.
These glands would be furiously attacked by Alexander's army complete villages.
They were burned to the ground and people were killed with impunity,
the Greek army and met their strongest resistance at the hands of king porous in
the Punjab region.
The Indian forces were defeated in battle,
but Alexander was so impressed with the tactics and bravery of porous that he
offered a co rulership to him while Alexander weed control the lands,
he would handle the day to day running of Punjab to pour us by.
Now,
Alexandra had conquered more territory than any other retailer in history,
but he was still not satisfied.
He wanted to advance even deeper into the Indian subcontinent.
However,
his army,
they didn't.
They are simply out enough.
The soldiers revolted,
refusing to advance any further.
The generals sided with the mint.
One of them general conus told Alexander,
but the man long to again see that parents,
their wives,
their children,
their homeland.
Alexander sympathized and decided that it was time to go home,
but he continued to conquer villages and claim more lands on his return route.
In order to do Blake ages,
man,
he sounded older and disabled soldiers directly back to Macedonia,
but this act,
it backfired.
The men thought that they were all going directly home.
We're not Xander march.
Then on further conquests,
there was a lot of anger.
The men of his army,
they began to openly criticize Alexander.
They were especially unhappy with his adoption of Persian customs and the
appointing of Persian officers to command them and an attempt to win favor
Alexander in should.
The Macedonian troops were ruled over by Macedonian officers.
He also held a huge banquet for his men to celebrate the years of victory.
After returning to pasture,
Alexandra established himself and the Great Palace of Nebuchadnezzar.
He plans further campaigns of conquest into a radio,
but these would never come to pass.
Alexander died suddenly on June the 10th will be 11 332 BCE.
The cause of death is unclear with there being two main theories and both of
these there is involved.
The excessive use of alcohol and one accounts.
He develops a fever after a 24 hour drinking binge and the other,
he became sick after drinking a bowl of unmixed wine.
Of course,
this also been talk of poisoning the death of the king of kings.
At the height of his power was a huge shock to the entire world.
People could not believe that such a strong dynamic and his heroic individual
could be struck down without wanting Alexander's body.
It was placed in a gold sarcophagus,
much disputing he was laid to rest and not Axondria even the next centuries.
Then eight famous leaders came to pay respects but his body,
it was not left in peace.
It is said that the Roman Emperor Augustus accidentally damaged the Kolbe.
Since Caligula stole Alexander's breastplates.
Such incidents prompted Emperor Septimius Severus to close the tomb to the
public in 200 CE where it was taken is unknown.
Today,
the location of Alexander's tomb is one of history's great mysteries.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Also,
please do check out our sponsor,
Squarespace.
Like I said,
that what Alexander the great would have used.
You find a link to them below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.